hello and welcome to the show my guest
today is a professor of German at the
University of Pennsylvania in
Philadelphia it is dr. Eric yar ocinski
or Jerry Sinskey I should say straight
away he's also very active on Twitter
indeed he's most probably better known
by his Twitter name nine quarterly nine
incidentally not the number but the
German word for no and by that I don't
mean no as in to know someone but no as
in yes confused well stage welcome to
the show
let's clear up that name straight away
why is that your Twitter handle well
let's see um I think partially it's
because what I'm largely interested in
doing on Twitter is about really
articulating a voice that is sort of a
grumpy misanthropic kind of voice who
says nine to great many things dislikes
a great many things dislikes Twitter
even most of the time but in doing so I
think is trying really to say yes to
something else and you'll probably ask
soon about the the rest of the name
which is this is a compendium of utopian
negation Thanks what this is its I'm
interested in working with a fair number
of cliches marketing slogans language
from advertising etc and taking a lot of
things that would give us a certain yes
to this is the good life or this is what
you want and saying no to that that and
well maybe you want something else but
you don't see very grumpy you have a big
smile I can't help it I'm from the
Midwest
in the United States were supposedly
nice people of course if you know us
better you'll just other very politic
people but well there is a difference
between myself and and and in this case
character that I've developed this voice
of developed but over time I've realized
that there's a fair amount of overlap as
well is it is it very definitely a
character then it's not
I mean you an actor on Twitter so to
speak well maybe I'm here as an actor
maybe actually do you have a monocle and
I've only put on my my glasses for today
well in a way or at least that's that's
maybe how it started the the short
version of a long story about the origin
of this is really that I was trying to
write an academic book that was having
real difficulty writing and it was
largely because I was frustrated with
the language of academia I was somewhat
frustrated with a topic that I've been
working as for many years and I found
myself really unable to write and
writer's block well so resort to Twitter
with a hundred and forty carries somehow
block is putting it mildly I'm not
exactly sure what what term I would use
except that it was it was no way
connected to a great deal of anxiety I'm
an anxious person actually and there was
a way in which Twitter and and and
developing this other voice was a way to
talk about the things I wanted to talk
about and then I care about and spend a
great deal time learning about but I
could do so in an irreverent way in a
playful way and I think ultimately I've
come to the conclusion in a way that's
really more in the spirit of the type of
critical thinkers I'm interested in
before we get to the irreverence yeah I
just want to clear up you mentioned the
monocle yes this is your avatar and this
well tell us about this this was
designed by somebody here in Germany I
mean yes yes Lucas wrote graphic
designer and yes in Dutch say a company
called font fabric in in Berlin type
designer and this came about as many
things have
I have a number of followers have been
very generous very supportive of what it
is that been doing and they pitched in
in various ways large and small and what
this is is a cartoon version of one of
the Philosopher's have worked on for
some time this is taya Davi O'Donnell
and he's of course most known for his
work on the Enlightenment on reason on
the culture industry is the term that he
coined together with Max Horkheimer did
he actually have a moniker that is that
is really putting my own stamp on this
because while he in in in in in many
ways is is is very engaged with with
with with popular culture and much of
his his work really is is is about that
and about sort of the politics of a pop
culture he's often vilified for being I
guess the term that we used today is
being very elitist and in a way I wanted
to play that up really this monocle of
sort of an aristocratic Adorno and and
that's really a way of for me in one
hand speaking to a certain perception of
this thinker but also for me it's a way
to comment on sort of the the the
industry that's growing up around him
and the sort of cultural capital that's
associated with him and that's part of
what made my own work somewhat difficult
was much of the the institutional
context of working on thinkers like this
and I really wanted to return to the
things that that first drew me to him
which were humor in it and actually I
think 60,000 followers now on Twitter
how many are they how many of them are
German that's a good question this is
really hard to figure out there are only
some very sort of crude tools for for
for determining that I think roughly
maybe
a third something like yeah yeah I think
it's time we should straight away yeah
here's one this is some one of your
aphorism song on Twitter if we can see
this one if you could read that out to
us I don't know where they are they can
see it now on the screen in English war
is hell in German hell is a summit sunny
day we should explain that little bit of
course one of those German words that as
a false friend in that hell of in in
German means bright right or clear and
there are plenty of examples of context
and shovel show one of my favorites is
seeing a light muffin at some point it
was called muffin Hill I've got one for
you actually I took a photograph this
very morning because I go past this
every day and it amuses me and with a
muse English speakers but of course this
is a sign for an interior decorator near
my house I mean I'm sure he's I'm sure
that terribly good really and of course
this hell is beer yes lager yes yes now
talking about tweeting how many do how
many tweets do you write every day
that's a number I wouldn't want to admit
to myself let alone to to to an audience
I would say the it didn't it varies a
lot it could be as many as 50 to 100
perhaps I would I would say that the
same time many of those many of those
are erased at the end of the day okay
well well we we were very curious about
where you do your tweeting because there
is so many so we asked dr. Eric to
quickly make some film on his smartphone
before he flew over from Philadelphia so
a world exclusive behind the scenes of
nine quarterly
and Eric you haven't seen this yourself
I'm afraid this is spontaneous can you
talk us through this roll film
well you see some rather avant-garde
filmmaking technique here this is me at
a bus stop waiting for a bus with time
it's the time to kill as it were it
arrives and this is the scene for much
of my my writing is in fact in France I
find that to be one of the most
productive times actually trains waiting
for anything
this is me simply walking through my
neighborhood in South Philadelphia she
tweet when you're you know I've become
one of those people yes and it's it's
dangerous it really is sometimes that
that the next joke about Hegel is more
important than looking before you cross
the street this is my office at the
University look how dark it is I don't
actually spend much time that I don't
write tweets there for sure finally
where's this is New York I split my time
between New York and Philadelphia I have
I have a nice view there but that's but
essentially to ask answer your question
I tweet most most most anywhere but
that's also sort of the explanation for
in a way why I'm doing this is that or
why I'm able to do it is I don't know if
I've ever written a tweet on my laptop
for instance if it weren't for the
smartphone I would never have started
this because why what I like about it is
that it is sort of an ongoing
conversation with your everyday life
with something that you see that that
that that inspires you in some way or
that you recognize some joke in or
whatever it happens to be but alone the
existence or do you actually interact
with a lot of your I certainly interact
but it's but it is both lonely and not
lonely I mean the Internet is all about
paradoxes so you don't need a professor
and a tide it's explained that I mean I
think we all know this but for me it's
the that most intensively have
experienced that paradox of being
somehow part of a community together in
some way but
every one separately and there's there's
actually that's one of the one of the
things I write about a fair amount and
in in in in my jokes about Twitter it's
essentially ways in which sometimes
social media succeeds and filling that
emptiness it's created in our lives and
I think that there's there something to
that that there is a type of community
but you also have to ask yourself what
what type of community is being lost at
the same time let me mention another
tweet not not on the iPad there until
there is truth until there is beauty
it's what I particularly like at least
there is German grammar because I've
been struggling with the last 20 years
how did you actually add your interest
start in the German language coincidence
more than anything I grew up in a tiny
little town very remote in in Wisconsin
in fact if you google my home town of
Park Falls Wisconsin you'll see that it
is also described as being one of the
most remote towns in in this very rural
part of the state I actually have a map
of it you do will be shown well I think
it got its four stoplights maybe ten
years ago two of them if I'm not
mistaken there might have caused
accidents with neighbors when they were
first installed how familiarity with
them but it's a you know the kind of
place where you have to travel two or
three hours didn't ever shopping mall
this is possible yeah so you learn
German yes well this is this is how
chance came in is that and there was a
student my high school who had spent a
year in Germany and Castle right outside
of Castle bonnet Holly and she returned
and spoke of the great wide world beyond
and as things happen we fell madly in
love and was together for many years and
much of the plan
this is guided far too many my decisions
in life but many of them have worked out
there's nothing better hunting guide
such decisions I believe people are
learning German uh-huh
from your from nine-course they are
learning a type of German German a fair
number of people that I've realized when
things are written in German and I do
mainly write in English but when I when
I write more in German and I do that
more when I'm gonna when I'm in Germany
a number of people run this through
Google Translate for instance
they it's always curious to see what
they thought they come out with because
largely I am playing with some aspect of
the language and those things obviously
don't translate so well hmm now your
what we haven't told our audience but
I'm going to now you're leaving I
believe a secure job as a professor at
the University in Pennsylvania of them
to dive into the unknown why why in a
way to leave the unknown yes a secure
existence I suppose maybe but you know
you're also talking to an academic who
is having real difficulty writing real
difficult real difficulty doing his
research I was at a research university
still him for a few more weeks at least
and that's your job I mean I teach
clearly but institutions like this are
about producing any number of
publications books articles etc and if
you have trouble writing well you won't
you won't be sticking on there very long
so this wasn't simply a rash decision I
mean certainly the the writing was very
much on the wall for me and if if
anything though I found that I've
greatly benefited from the experience
from my years at the University and I
think that that's a lot of what I do
comes from that experience as well
certainly many people who follow our
academics
and there are a number of things that I
write that are really for other
academics so very in very much inside
jokes along those lines okay
so in a way yes I'm departing but on to
bigger and better things in many ways
yeah well well we we were looking for a
report that might help you it's not easy
to turn tweets into money but there's a
German woman who says Twitter has
actually been good for business in just
a few minutes she draws people that
she's never even seen before the hey
LaVon I've Berger only knows them
through Twitter the online forum he
transforms strangers tweets of 140
characters or less into pictures then
she takes a photograph and posts it on
Twitter sometimes she writes tweets
about whatever Mooser just one or two
sentences like playing ping pong with
your thoughts
these small spontaneous drawings are
often freely associated with the
pseudonyms chosen by those depicted in
her Twitter portraits
she follows the entries posted by nearly
1000 people who have Twitter profiles it
provides her with a seemingly
inexhaustible source of creative energy
I always keep an eye on Twitter
I can't even calculate the hours I spend
doing it anymore so it's better not to
ask
it certainly has an addictive potential
someone even wrote about it for heaven's
sake it's a horrible drug but it's fun
so you really get addicted to it what
Twitter is also about opportunity
Michaela has long become a star on the
scene her agency has got Commission's
from it and four galleries invited her
to exhibit her drawings
that gave her the chance to finally get
to know some of her twitter friends in
real life the first exhibition was held
at a gallery in Nuremberg Mikkel I met
the real people behind the drawings and
she could check to see how well she hit
the mark one Twitter user came from
Berlin when something you care about
hurts then it's real and that's what I
drew it's an honor to see it online
Mikaela fun hike beggars drawings from
the Twitter world made their real world
debut and of course they gave Twitter
users something to talk about naturally
those users instantly posted their
impressions of the exhibition for the
whole world to see now normally on the
show we have a prize draw where we give
something away now 9 quarterly is all
about negation so this week Eric has
kindly agreed to donate nothing as a
prize so write to us at insite at DW de
and we will then pick a winner who will
receive receive even precisely nothing
but it will be nothing from my guest
it's gonna cost a fortune to mail
there's a lot of nothing right you're
out in the real world do you like
meeting your fans or have you met any of
your fans
yes I've missed several actually it's
and some people I've known from real
life and then they start to follow me
although that's really a very small
number but yes in fact it's one of the
most exciting things about about this
for me has been even when I had many far
fewer followers they were so spread out
around the world that anywhere I would
go I know that there's somebody there
who follows this thing and I might meet
with them or simply get some restaurant
tips find out what what you know what
bar to go to or
any number of ways in which that local
knowledge that's it's so interesting
valuable changes your experience of a
place so you know I've met a good number
of them I'll meet some one on traveling
around now a little bit so no it's one
of the fun things about it we're talking
before that report about you know you're
giving up your job and I you want to be
a professional a forest somebody who
writes perhaps sayings or witticisms I
mean let me ask you how do you think
you're gonna make a living well let me
tell you well this is still figuring at
the moment but I've got a good start I
knowing quarterly now runs as a weekly
column and the German newspaper DEET
site and that's that's been for like the
last five six weeks at this point and
it's an experiment essentially taking it
this is I should just say this is a
highly regarded if not the best sort of
German weekly newspaper well now it is
for the last five or six weeks yes but
it's a ya know it's it's it's it's it's
one of those papers that I have spent a
great deal time reading in the past
great all the time looking upwards
because the German is sometimes
complicated for me it certainly was in
the past in a publication like that
excuse me but the so there's that that's
Rd that's already begun I've actually
started writing somewhat longer pieces
now I've done some things recently for
the fan pataga Minor which again very
highly regarded German newspaper and I
think there's a real interest in an
American perspective on Germany from an
American who spent a great deal of time
here and who has the language who has
friends here has a rather different
perspective than what you'll get from
some other figures perhaps and in
politics business etc who drop in and on
the way out again after a short amount
of time and I think that that that what
people have appreciated has been that
sort of in-between position that I
occupy and that's really what it is that
I love most about what it is that that
that I have been doing over the last
years that really living between these
cultures they were talking of that
actually I'd like to show you stop show
a few pictures now this first one this
is some your entry into Bond University
and I believe but this I do know because
you told me beforehand that your first
experience in Germany in Bonn was being
locked in the universe yes it's not
because of anything I did necessarily
but it was wanted to look at the main
university building this rather ornate
Palace essentially on a Saturday and I
went with my girlfriend at the time and
we walked in and we went to leave a few
minutes later and we were locked inside
of this building and it turns out there
was an alarm that went off fifteen
minutes before they closed but we came
in somehow after the alarm and it made
for some harrowing moments he had to
call the police hang outside of the
window essentially the signal where we
were how did you call the police we
found the one the one public telephone
in that building and this is before the
days that everyone had a cell phone but
it didn't pull you off you studied in
Bonn I said it and you studied in a
number of places and even taught in
Freiburg I know but another picture now
of the city were in there Berlin because
you've actually you've lived here for
quite a time - yeah this is a that's
funny that's a picture from my believer
this 1991-1992 it's my my first trip to
to Berlin and standing there with a
couple of friends of mine marks and
angles marks is actually someone I teach
a lot actually in the university
and yeah that was my first trip it was
an exciting time to to be here I mean
much of my my experience of Germany has
been really post ball Germany my very
first trip I think 1990 until the
present and so it's been a really
fascinating place to be for those years
mmm now we're about halfway through the
show now and you haven't been able to
Twitter as you all right yeah I'm fine
actually people often will say that but
no I I'm careful about that it's it's
actually something I've had to learn to
be careful about could you get addicted
do you think oh sure of course the
reason I mentioned not specifically for
you but a lot of talk isn't there at the
moment about social media and I mean
Twitter hasn't been denigrated much but
I mean Facebook is being I mean and
stuff yeah well I like to say it's not
an addiction it's a it's just a rather
frequent light motif but yes no I think
it certainly has that potential I'm sure
that I probably am addicted in some
manner but at the same time it's it's
it's also what's made it possible to
continue doing it is that I've been able
to find a way in which it fills moments
that would otherwise not necessarily be
spent doing something else a lot of it
is sort of an internal monologue which
now finds its way onto the Internet
but no in lots of ways I have a
relationship that means a lot to me and
when we're together i I never tweet it's
that would certainly get in the way of a
healthy relationship mm-hmm I'm trying
to find one of I think that's it as I'm
trying to find another tweet that I
think it's time for another tweet if we
can put this one this one is a gentle
reminder that there is most certainly a
German sense of humor it is however
commonly mistaken is what he attracts
that one is open to interpretation I
suppose except to say that I guess it
would either equip about about German
humorous that it just doesn't translate
especially into German of course is all
unfair but that's a lot of what I do
really is to exaggerate cliches
exaggerate various stereotypes and
that's something I very much enjoy doing
in that it's a way to in which you can
explore those things make fun of things
but do so in a very accessible way and
also good that I enjoy
how do jaemin's react to of the
observations they react differently to
other people I mean I've read that you
said Germans have a different way of
reading Twitter yes that's been my sense
anyway and this relates to your question
about how much I write per day yes it
actually be much better for me if I
wrote less to stick with my account you
have to be committed to it because
you'll see a lot of it and I could
understand how that could be frustrating
for some people but I think that for my
German followers in particularly the
sense that I have is that one has a
greater sense of duty obligation to read
every tweet that happens to be in one's
timeline and especially with the time
difference if when you wake up in the
morning you're gonna find everything
that I had written that the night before
essentially and that could be a bit much
I mean at one go and so I frequently
receive the complaint that I like what
you're right but there's simply too much
of it I had I can't I can't I can't I
can't deal with it
and I understand I mean it's a but but
largely I have to say a German followers
have shown
really the things they get a joke and
and they have a sense of humor about
themselves and was it the German
following it said I know you get sent
with your avatar so that there's a
Photoshop this we have to say yes yes
this is well you tell us who this well
one of the best-known philosophers of
our days logic and this is this is a
picture I think actually my logo my nine
here is taking the place of a poster of
Stalin which is actually the thing but I
rather like I don't know whether I hope
people could see this there's the coffee
carpet yes well but I did I did go into
some merchandising for a few weeks I did
yes yes I however it was it was a little
experiment it was something that people
liked sold a few things you don't make
much money but it was but it was fun but
after a while I I just decided it wasn't
really for me at least not for now
because you know as much as what I do is
just you know these silly little jokes
or you know you can call them aphorisms
if you like but I think of it as writing
jokes it also means a great deal to me I
mean it came along in a time of my life
in which things are very difficult and
this is also now and you know to try to
avoid a few clichés but actually making
it a new life possible and so to me it
does mean something and the experiences
that I've had on have been meaningful
and so there are ways in which I'm
cautious myself about cheapening the
experience so that was that was in the
end I'd like a coffee table having
that's cheap well right right now
they're collectors items because there
aren't many out there oh my guest is
Eric garrison ski who's amusing his
Twitter followers with international
aphorisms or jokes as it says on Germany
in the German language now the author
Franz Kafka wasn't exactly thought of as
being funny or indeed light but one
history institution here in Germany has
been trying to change that I wonder what
you think of that is it dumbing down
caf-co you're an intellectual you're a
professor is it dumbing him down or is
it making more accessible
well I think actually a cough is funny
without a comics coffee it's hilarious
in many ways it's I mean it's a very
dark comedy but it's but it's comedy if
you think about it the fact that Kafka
that the GoM's awakes you know one
morning as this this this giant
monstrous vermin and his first thought
is how do I get to work right there's
something tragically funny about that
and to me that's that's the type of
humor that that I appreciate and there's
something isn't nothing is funny for me
unless it also acknowledges really how
sad it all is yeah I guess reading your
Twitter feed you know it's that's quite
one thing I wanted to mention when in
doubt umlaut yes that we have to explain
the umlaut is the two dots above all the
vowels know some of the vowels
yeah that change the sound of the word
ring that make if you put if you have it
above a you it's mm-hmm if it's above an
a it's Oh a it's it's it sounds that
English speakers don't really have
that's right yeah it's I guess what
interest is interest me about it for one
thing is yes it's something unique of
course Turkish has loads as well even
many more than usual even more
frequently that in German many my
Turkish followers have have told me this
but also it's graphically interesting I
mean the the um load in particular I
mean something that I very much like
about Twitter and it's just seeing and
you know you just have a little bit of
text in front of you but you start to
look at that text differently
and certainly I'm not the first to
realize this but you know a you lout is
is is an interesting little cute little
smiley right and you look at it from a
certain perspective right this I'm just
realizing this would really what you've
just said would really upset the
heavy-metal community but for me the om
loud is actually an expression of shock
or surprise in fact one of my favorite
bits of stick to do is that of German
emoticons which are typically unloaded
vowels but it's so does that explain why
bands like Motorhead Blue Oyster Cult
I'm trying to think of others Motley
Crue Motley Crue if you try to pronounce
them with the umlaut actually but
something rather unusual it has a
history and wikipedia has an entry on
the heavy metal umlaut which is which is
worth reading it's it's interesting and
it's a signifier of so many things it's
really a complex signifier of one
associates German as' somehow with that
and that has a whole range of other
associations as well in particular you
know the questions of typeface etc I
think largely though what it does is
that it at least connotes some sense of
gravitas of weight in some ways of a
type of seriousness earnestness of some
sort that then can be exaggerated in the
case of say heavy metal that sort of
playing on a certain darkness right and
and in others what I like to do with it
is really to to both have it present and
not and that's what I like about an
amount of this thing that you might
associate with much of the gloom and
doom that I that that that feels my
tweets but at the same time yeah it's a
smiling yeah yeah enough of German
grammar I want and this is a photo you
took in Philadelphia perhaps
yeah actually well this is one that
someone sent me but it's taken on
Philadelphus right and it's um but this
shows up a lot in Philadelphia recently
and it's not my work I will I will add
that well the same thing I believe in
Vanna Hanson yes it's become it's become
something of a motif but I think always
the same the same persons behind it I
recognize the penmanship there but Vanna
hats August become certainly has been
and and become even more of a cult
figure in the United States and a
certain certain scene and there is some
of some of that which I think also comes
from the fact that his voice is so
important and what he does his
perspective sort of this hyper-rational
in a way perspective yet at the same
time a hyper-rational dreamer of some
sort who has a certain vision and is
obsessed by things and I think that he
embodies many of the contradictions that
I'm interested in exploring and what
would I do online I won't have sort of
finally broaden that out a bit from
Vanna Hertzog that that picture in in in
Philadelphia on the popularity or
unpopular out or how is Germany mhm
perceived I mean you're an exception as
a guest actually because normally our
guests live here and I wonder if you
finally could tell us what how do you
think Germany is perceived today in
Middle America
yeah well interesting and right now I
think that that in some ways many of the
old caches might live on much of the
image of Germany has been shaped by
tourism Bavaria is usually what people
think of immediately of course people
associate German Germans history of
course the Nazi period still lives on in
people's in people's memories as it
should but it's certainly not the the
only aspect that that people think about
now
but I think what's what's Happ
and largely has been that much of the
culture that's grown up around Berlin of
course that has been here for some time
but that has been discovered in more
recent decades by Americans the British
etc that that has also made its way back
into American culture and that there is
something about that kind of Berlin
scene that has been replacing I think
many of the older the shays event about
Germany in the u.s. dr. Eric Jerez insky
has been fascinating talk to you good
luck take all your writing look out for
him on nine quarterly don't forget also
to write to us at insights at DWD this
week you can win absolutely nothing but
dr. Jarris Hinske who's be my guest on
inside Germany this week thanks for
watching
join us again Lex at the same time next
week bye bye
you